All right.
So
let's go through the changes
that I'm making.
So, first of all, all of these cats are
going to be in an unordered list, and
each one of them will be a list item.
Now, how do I make an li for
every single one of our cats?
I can say ul data-bind
is foreach: catList.
That will make an li for
each one of the items inside of catList.
And inside of the li,
I'm going to add data-bind as well.
It's going to have text
as the name of the cat.
If I save this and refresh it in
the browser, let's see what happens.
And sure enough,
we get the list of all of our cats here.
Pretty good.
Now we've got our cats showing
up in a list, all we need to do
is make the current cat change
when you click on one of them.
That second part is a little
bit more difficult.
We know that we need
a click somewhere in here.
We don't necessarily
know what it will be yet.
But we want a click on this
list item to somehow wire up to
something inside of app.js.
Now like I said,
bindings can be a little bit difficult
because it's a little bit more difficult
to visualize where you are,
what your binding context is.
I might normally feel inclined to do
something like this, on click, setCat.
And then in our app.js,
down here in the ViewModel, as it
turns out, that's not going to work.
Here's why.
When you click on this, it looks for
setCat within this binding context,
which is within the cat itself.
What we need to do is get up outside of
that binding context to the view model.
The way we get up out of a binding
context is using $.parent.
I'm going to save both of these, and
I'll put a console.log statement
in here just to make sure.
If I go back to my browser here and
I refresh, sure enough now,
when I click on this,
I get console.logs of hi.
Now, rather than running console.log,
all I have to do is
update the current cat.
To access the current cat,
I'm going to use self.currentCat.
Remember, self is referring
to the ViewModel and
that is where currentCat lives.
And what are we going to set it to?
Well, if you look in the documentation
for click, you'll find that when you
click on something and it runs
a function, it passes in the object
you clicked on, specifically
the model we're talking about.
So when setCat gets run, and
the clickedCat model gets passed in,
we're going to set the currentCat
to the clickedCat,
to the one we just clicked on.
Let's save this and hop back into
the browser and see if that works.
Now if I click on Shadow,
sure enough, it changes.
And if I click, you can see that
Shadow has his own counter and
Tiger has his own counter, etc.
So now we've made the cats
show up in a list.
We've made the current cat change
when you click on one of them.
I hope you've given
yourself a high five.
Although giving yourself a high
five is kind of just a clap, so
go find someone else and
give them a high five.
You just built together with
me a pretty amazing app, and
a lot of it was driven by
you doing it yourself, going
through the documentation, learning
things on your own, and trying things.
Seriously good work.